this is a Supreme Court sanctioned
murder of what little actual democracy
is left in this democracy corporations
do not think they do not breathe they do
not have a conscience undo the
disastrous disastrous impact to our
democracy that Citizens United has done
I think of sort of the movement and
struggle to win rights for corporations
as sort of one of the least well-known
yet most successful civil rights
movements in American history Citizens
United vs. Federal Election Commission
was a landmark 2010 Supreme Court case
concerning regulation of money spent on
communications by corporations because
of First Amendment protections on free
speech the court ruled that the
government couldn't restrict
corporations from spending money on
political ads right before an election
last week the Supreme Court reversed a
century of law that I believe will open
the floodgates for special interests
including foreign corporations to spend
without limit in our elections
but a new book called we the
corporation's by UCLA Law Professor Adam
Winkler debunk some common wisdom about
the Citizens United decision and it even
complicates the narrative about the
founding of America what was the impetus
for writing this book well in recent
years the Supreme Court has held the
corporations have free speech rights and
citizens united saying they the same
right as individuals to spend money to
influence elections and religious
liberty rights the Supreme Court in the
Hobby Lobby saying that the national
chain of craft stores was entitled to an
exemption from an Obamacare rule that
required large employers to cover birth
control and these cases raised an
interesting question which is how did
corporations come to have our most
fundamental rights like free speech and
religious freedom and so I wanted to
look into that history and what I found
was really remarkable that corporations
have been fighting for equal rights for
over 200 years and while unlike say
women and racial minorities who fought
for their rights by protesting in the
streets and marching and parading with
signs and making public advocacy for
their rights corporations don't engage
in that kind of mass mobilization but
they have fought in the Supreme Court to
win landmark rulings by the justices
extending the most fundamental rights in
the Constitution to them and today they
have nearly all the same rights as you
and me yeah it kind of happened on the
down-low it sort of happened in
courtrooms across hundreds of years
until what got until we got till today I
think of sort of the movement and
struggle to win rights for corporations
as sort of one of the least well-known
yet most successful civil rights
movements in American history a
corporation is not a person we now see
effectively a corporate takeover of our
democracy it is government of the people
by the corporations for the corporations
everyone says citizens united was based
on this idea of corporate personhood and
one thing I knew just reading and
teaching citizens united is that that
idea actually never comes out in the
opinion the Supreme Court opinion never
says corporate personhood doesn't rely
on that idea instead the court says that
corporations are associations of people
and that a business corporation like
Exxon this
essentially like the n-double-a-cp a
voluntary membership organization that
people support and endorse for their
politics and for their larger vision
rather than just to make money and
that's a controversial way of thinking
about the corporation but it's actually
one that runs throughout the Supreme
Court history occasionally the Supreme
Court has said that corporations are
people but much more common is the
Supreme Court is that corporations have
rights because the people within them
who associate together they are people
and they have rights yeah it's a
listeners rights theory can you just
like explain that for anybody who's like
me and is not a person with a lot of
great
well the story of the listeners rights
theory of the First Amendment is one
that also shows how Ralph Nader was a
really important influence that gave us
Citizens United
so back in the 1978 Oh Ralph Nader Ralph
Nader the consumer rights advocate in
the 1970s Ralph Nader's organization
Public Citizen their litigation arm
brought a landmark case to the Supreme
Court challenging restrictions on
pharmacists advertising of drug prices a
Nader was interested in not helping
pharmacist but in helping consumers
comparison shop on these prices and
these laws prevented the consumers from
getting that information and he takes
the case to the Supreme Court and he
argues that the First Amendment protects
those rights of consumers to get
accurate information and that this law
is unconstitutional the Supreme Court
agrees with him and adopts this
listeners theory of the First Amendment
that same theory would then be used in
cases like citizens united and an
important case that I talked about in my
book that often goes overlooked case in
the 1970s called the pilate case where
the Supreme Court even years before
citizens united said that corporations
had political speech rights and what the
court said in these cases is not that
corporations are people that have
political speech rights but that if
anything that corporations speech is
protected because the listeners of
corporate speech will want to hear it
and value that speech and their rights
mean that corporations can't be
prevented from speaking what do you
think Ralph Nader is gonna say when he
thumbs through your book and he sees oh
Ralph Nader's Public Citizen led to
citizens united well it is true that
Public Citizen in year sense has come to
argue that the whole line of Supreme
Court cases that come out of the
Virginia pharmacy case the Ralph Nader
case in the 1970s should be overturned
because today the First Amendment is
used largely by corporations and trade
associations that represent businesses
to fight against regulation and in fact
a recent empirical study found that 50%
of current First Amendment cases that
are brought today are brought by
corporations and businesses and trade
associations but it's not as if
corporations somehow decided to take
over America one day Winkler says
corporations have been around ever since
the first Europeans set foot on American
soil in the 1600s one of the fascinating
things I found when writing we the
corporation's was sort of the early
history of America of America is tied to
this image of the Pilgrims right who
were sort of the perfect example of what
the American identity would come to be
they were escaping tyranny they were
exercising their fundamental rights of
freedom of religion
there were self-governing and you know
Hardy people who were out there in the
wilderness but thirteen years before the
pilgrims came in Plymouth the first
permanent English colony was established
back down in Jamestown and it was
established as a business corporation it
was set up by the Virginia Company of
London one of England's first stock
corporations and it was a money-making
enterprise and the people who were sent
were not dissenters or outcasts or
people fighting against the king they
were basically employees and investors
of the Virginia Company of London and
they were here to try to turn a profit
and as I tell in the book that in some
ways that one of the founding people
behind the United States behind the
American experience was the Virginia
Company of London a very important
corporation that introduced
representative democracy to America and
not because of some impulse to have
progressive reforms but rather as a way
of enticing people to come to the new
world by giving them a measure of
autonomy again because it was a
struggling business corporation that was
trying to
turn a profit Winkler says even
important American documents like the
Bill of Rights and the Constitution were
influenced by the structure of a
corporation the colonies were originally
set up as corporations and they were
governed by colonial corporate charters
charters given to the corporation's and
the organizers by the government and the
charters would lay out very clearly what
office holders were in the corporation
what the rights were of the stockholders
how often they had to have meetings and
these various things that morphed into
basically charters of government I
wonder why the corporate story sort of
didn't find its way into the zeitgeist
like how did that how did we miss this
well I think part of the story is is
that we look back at our history and see
what we want to see in us today and I
think when we look back at that founding
era we think of ourselves more in the
framework of the pilgrims they they sort
of represent the America that we want to
become but the story of America is of
course always more nuanced a more
complicated a good example of that
nuance was the first corporate rights
Supreme Court case in 1809 where we
began to see how corporations would use
the First Amendment to say that they too
had a right to be heard in the American
legal system and it was called Bank of
the United States versus tuvo it's one
of the neglected overlooked landmarks of
American constitutional law in my
opinion and that case involved the Bank
of the United States which at the time
was one of the most powerful
corporations in the new world with
branches all the way from Boston to New
Orleans at a time when most businesses
were very local and the Bank of the
United States is famous for giving rise
to a split among the founders with
Jefferson and Hamilton fighting each
other and I mean the guy for the musical
right yeah exactly giving rise to the
two competing parties but that not only
did it give us rise to the two competing
parties and a good rap battle and
Hamilton the musical but also gave rise
to this first Supreme Court case the
bank when Jeffersonians imposed the tax
on the bank the bank went to federal
court and said we have a constitutional
right under article 3 of the
Constitution to sue Georgia who put
impose this tax on us in federal court
the problem was is that provision of the
Constitution only guarantees the right
to sue in federal court to citizens and
yet a corporation was claiming that
right to and although of course
corporations are not citizens and the
framers didn't write that provision
thinking about corporations the supreme
court in an opinion by legendary Chief
Justice John Marshall held the
corporations indeed were protected by
that provision and did have the right to
sue in federal court under this
provision for citizens it's worth noting
that a half-century later in the Dred
Scott case the Supreme Court would say
that African Americans could not be
citizens under that exact same provision
of the Constitution Dred Scott v Sanford
was a landmark decision from 1857 saying
slaves were not citizens of the United
States and therefore could not sue in
federal court the decision was later
overturned in 1868 by the 14th amendment
the 14th memo was adopted after the
Civil War to protect the rights of the
newly freed slaves guaranteeing them
equal protection of the laws and
although the Supreme Court in years to
come would refuse to recognize that
African Americans have significant
rights under the 14th amendment in cases
like
Plessy against Ferguson upholding Jim
Crow laws Supreme Court really didn't
read the 14th amendment vibrantly to
protect African Americans until Brown
versus Board of Education in the 1950s
so many many years almost a century
after it was adopted but in that time
corporations actually took advantage of
that and and one rights under the 14th
amendment the Southern Pacific Railroad
launched a remarkable series of cases in
the 1880s what lawyers called test cases
designed specifically to give
corporations Fourteenth Amendment rights
and it was a crazy series of cases two
of them made it to the Supreme Court in
the first the Southern Pacific
Railroad's lawyer who's an illustrious
man who has once nominated and confirmed
to the Supreme Court himself a guy named
Roscoe Conkling he lied to the Supreme
Court claiming that the framers of the
14th amendment intended to protect
business corporations and he testified
from his own experience he had been one
of the framers of the Fourteenth
Amendment but it turns out that
historians now know that he did not tell
the truth
Supreme Court when Conkling argued his
case before the Supreme Court in 1882 he
was the last surviving member of the
drafting committee of the 14th amendment
so there was no one there to refute his
story you talk about like so many test
cases brought by corporations why are
they so good on it and why
maybe person's real persons a human
human beings every well or not well it
turns out the court system is a perfect
playing field for business corporations
business corporations have enabled had
the resources to hire the most expensive
lawyers that money can buy in the
country you know think about civil
rights movements and the women's rights
movement traditionally underfunded
struggle to have enough resources to
bring cases by expensive you mean really
good lawyers people that cost a lot of
money right get results right I mean the
reason why those lawyers are the most
expensive lawyers in the country is
because they're often the best lawyers
in the country they're often great
lawyers that don't charge as much money
and if we think about this great the the
great lawyers of the civil rights
movement like Thurgood Marshall was
never paid much money was a great great
lawyer Ruth Bader Ginsburg in the
women's rights movement but there have
also been great lawyers on behalf of
Business Corporations all the way back
to Daniel Webster who is one of the
greatest Supreme Court advocates ever
argued more than 220 cases in the
Supreme Court in the early 1800s many of
them on behalf of Business Corporations
and seeking constitutional protections
for business clients and so corporations
have always been able to one hire the
best lawyers that money can buy two
always had the appetite for risk
willingness to to pursue potentially
losing lawsuits because you know if you
can defeat a regulation that really
prevents you from making millions and
millions of dollars the fact that you
might spend a little bit of money
challenging that law in court it's just
the cost of doing business and so and
today for instance there's an elite
Supreme Court Bar in Washington that is
that studies show is much more effective
at getting their cases heard by the
Supreme Court and that those lawyers
today represent primarily Business
Corporations
one of the most interesting parts your
book is
this sort of liberal fight for for
corporations in the First Amendment it's
sort of stories that we don't really
think about when we think about Citizens
United but a lot of them come from
newspapers newspapers suing for their
free speech rights newspapers or
corporations New York Times Washington
Post if you will tell us that story I
mean it's like I think people forget
that like the the place where we get the
news also makes money that's right and
we the corporations it's not very
reductionist when you look back at this
history you find that actually liberals
will often arguing for the rights of
corporations and that I find actually
surprising limits on the rights of
corporation were imposed by the supreme
court in the notorious Lochner era a
period in the courts history where it
was very business-friendly but yet
nonetheless imposed limits on the rights
of corporations the story you asked
about with is really the story about
about the newspaper corporations who in
the 1930s took on Huey Long
Louisiana's iron-fisted demagogue who
was the governor in the senator and long
won the governorship of Louisiana on the
eve of the Great Depression promising to
make Louisiana great again and it's sort
of a Donald Trump thing he was Trump
before Trump and he really was he was a
populist who was great at using the
media and a showman and it news ya know
and in fact when the major newspapers in
Louisiana came out against Huey Long's
populism and his program he accused them
of publishing fake news and his allies
imposed attacks on newspaper
corporations on their advertising and
those newspapers challenged that tax in
court and won a landmark ruling one of
the very first Supreme Court rulings
striking down a law for violating the
freedom of the press the court said that
the free issued a broad opinion that's
still cited to this day for press
freedoms and the court said that
corporations have that right to that in
a modern democracy newspapers check
government and courage democratic
deliberation and they're published by
corporations that's an important
precedent from the 1930s that ends up
being cited by the Supreme Court
all the way including in citizens united
as establishing that corporations do
have free speech rights even when they
impact politics this is a devastating
security breach that was leaked out of
the Pentagon the most highly classified
documents of the war the time says 7,000
pages detailing how the White House has
been lying about the Vietnam War for 30
years the post this celebrated movie of
the past year that has liberals cheering
about the Washington Post standing up
for its First Amendment rights we should
remember that's a for-profit business
corporation standing up for its First
Amendment rights the right to engage in
political speech so it does show that
the story behind citizens united is a
complicated one and it's not just a
matter of sort of conservative
free-market principles applied to
campaign finance law as many people
suggest but actually it's a deeply
rooted issue that corporations have had
already long before Citizens United
established a toehold in American
political speech by using the
Constitution to expand their rights now
many people think about the
n-double-a-cp being a corporation it's a
people think of it as an association of
people but it definitely had to fight
for its free speech rights you talk
about a little bit in the book can you
talk about that here yeah well so for a
long time the Supreme Court said that
business corporations and corporations
generally do not have a freedom of
association and what happened in the
1950s is that after Brown versus Board
of Education there were southern states
that tried to put the n-double-a-cp out
of business stop them from filing
lawsuits in their states and I tell the
story about Alabama's effort to shut
down that n-double-a-cp
now of course the n-double-a-cp was not
a business but it turns out it was a
corporation and it's formed and
organized as a corporation under New
York law a nonprofit corporation but
takes the corporate form nonetheless and
Alabama tried to use the fact that it
was a corporation to put it out of
business to say that we have power to to
fight against this corporation and post
special rules on this corporation and
the corporation is no freedom of
association to hide its membership from
us for instance this
Court delivers an important victory for
the n-double-a-cp saying the
n-double-a-cp does even though it's a
corporation it does have certain
fundamental rights of association that
case would then be sided years later in
cases brought by Business Corporations
and indeed in Citizens United the
Supreme Court kind of envisions Business
Corporations to be like the
n-double-a-cp kind of voluntary
membership associations that have the
same kind of reason for people coming
together and joining up what's been your
reaction to people politicians that say
they want to overturn Citizens United
they are you know raising money creating
a lot of attention with this sort of
thing what's your been your reaction as
a law professor well there has been as
vibrant movement to amend the
Constitution to overturn citizens united
and I think about 19 states have
endorsed a constitutional amendment that
would declare corporations have no
rights and are not people under the
Constitution and while I sympathize with
the idea that citizens united maybe have
has given corporations and private
individuals too much leeway to spend as
much money as they want to influence
elections I think that the
constitutional amendment to deny
corporations all rights would be a real
mistake and will go way too far
corporations must have property rights
or the government can come seize their
property to build them all without
paying just compensation that can't be
right and corporations must have some
basic constitutional protections
otherwise CNN or the New York Times
could both be censured by Donald Trump
because they're both corporations they
must have some protections against such
government abuse at the same time I
think what's become real controversial
is that in recent years the Supreme
Court has ignored a line that the
Supreme Court drew a hundred years ago
100 years ago the Supreme Court said
corporations have property rights but
not liberty rights that they weren't
entitled to the rights of personal
conscience or political freedom that
ordinary people have but they were
entitled to property protections it
established a principle that the Supreme
Court today seems to have forgotten and
I think much of the controversy comes
from extending these fundamental Liberty
rights to corporations is the answer to
citizens united more speech or is that
just quixotic well I think one of the
difficulties is and under Citizens
United if corporations have the right to
spend as much money as they want to
influence elections but
cause of the unique ability of
corporations to amass capital it really
does give corporations extensively more
rights than individuals because it'd be
hard for very many individuals to match
the financing that say one company Apple
could put together if it wanted to
influence elections but we've seen at
least so far that corporations
especially the biggest biggest
brand-name corporations have often
stayed at the sidelines since citizens
united uncertain about whether this kind
of spending is a good idea for politics
or not but we're seeing corporations get
more and more involved in our political
lives look in the wake of the parklands
shooting we've seen a whole bunch of
businesses like Delta and Dick's
Sporting Goods and Walmart kind of take
on the NRA so these days we're expecting
more of our corporations to engage in
political life so maybe citizens united
is finding more of a home than people
realize are they staying on the
sidelines because of public shaming or a
public a public that might be
uncomfortable with them being an
election so much well I think we look
back in history what we see is that
often corporations have have seen
windows for them to be more active in
terms of political spending but they've
been hesitant to take advantage of those
windows often for fear of alienating
customers for feeling alienating workers
but we'll have to see what what time
will tell so far we've seen from
citizens united it's unleashed more
independent spending by individuals than
it has by Business Corporations we'll
have to see how that carries through in
the next few cycles well thank you very
much Adam we enjoyed talking to you
thank you for having me the book is
called we the corporations for reason
and poly-drug